these are it begins I'll just show you
the first one and then really the rest
I'm kind of tired the similar sort of
pattern I think for a memory it's this
yeah okay so when you look at this the
first thing your brain does is just kind
of explode because yeah this does not
fit in the categories of what I'm used
to working with okay you could try and
make Y the subject but then you kind of
end up with like it's a bit of a mess
really like I don't really know what to
do with this until your Midwife actually
it does fit into a category that we've
seen before it's just that we didn't
meet it in the context of this question
which is to graph we met it in the
context of trying to generate a general
solution for something like this I think
I gave me is okay there's like one of
the first examples we did in general
session right but to try and get towards
something which was easier more
formulaic to work with I said look this
is really this what is it it's PI on
three and so wherever you've got cause
something caused something right you can
use the general solution because every
time these two lines intersect this guy
going up and down and up and down and
this guy just going flat lining right
these are gonna be all of your solutions
so we understand that now this same idea
I can apply over here because again I've
got caused something cause something
we're just kind of weeding out a little
bit because one of them is a variable
and it's a different variable but that's
all right don't panic I'm gonna start in
just the same way that I started over
there which is to say it should be many
many solutions to this right multiple
solutions and there will be at every
even multiple of Pi okay now whatever
that means in this context what happens
in the end more to that is this formula
and up
also - yeah so I pound three over there
now the egg goal I'm dealing with is X
now I've done like the algebra use the
floor what does it mean I don't know
what it means you whatever point out is
and I should be technically correct I've
been a bit lazy doing this what I just
wrote is shot here it strong-headed
two ways right because we know how much
repetition love to take long sort of
sentences and birds and I could be and
boil it down the symbols that mean you
know as as B's economical as possible
this M what a really stands for is not
just a number not just an integer it
stands for all of the integers right and
that's why this is the general solution
it's a list really of all of the
different multiples of 2/pi okay so this
really means
okay you know what whatever this stands
for you've got an ear for a bunch of
them okay and they happen every two pi
so there me a 2pi version of four pi
vote at six papers on and so on there's
another piece of shorthand in my
equation what is it it's not much else
left is there is the plus or minus right
which is itself shorthand for this two n
pi there's a negative case and to employ
there's a positive case yeah so down
what I've got is for starters the two n
PI tells me I've got an infinite list of
things okay and then the plus or minus
toes we actually I've got two infinite
lists of things okay so what do these
look like just like before when I said
okay this is what your general solution
is but what are the actual like what the
values that are in to you now boy in
this case the first time would be N
equals zero which is final three what
would the little bit for any cause and
I'm gonna go forward I'm going to do
because again this is two lists right
I'm from N equals 1 it's 2 pi plus that
which is 7 PI + 3 and then there's the
teen PI on 3 and so on
there's the positiveness and then I have
the negative list which is negative PI
on 3
Payan three and so on okay so good so in
the same way that I'm like yeah this is
weird it's very hot static this is what
it really needs this is weird and this
is abstract so what does it really mean
well just like I did over here let's
let's tap these solutions okay we'll do
the positive case first just like I did
here then we'll do than anyone if I'm
looking at the positive case which is
this guy I was thinking about N equals
zero first y equals zero pi plus X Y cos
x oh there we go
case number one next and equals once and
y equals two pi plus X well looks like
just this guy but shifted up to PI units
okay
what's the next week saying your pen
budget this is N equals two so it's
going to be 4 PI plus X so that's let's
see not consistent and of course this is
also going to go up in the negative
direction because there's no reason why
I can't put in N equals Justin zebra so
I'm gonna get these guys as well okay so
here are all of these go so all of these
guys here are five of them okay and
these go on forever those are the
positive cases now I do the negative
ones what's the difference what's the
difference it's just a gradient right I
mean just think you our y equals MX plus
B form all the y-intercepts the bees are
the same still getting naught 2 pi 4 PI
all that's different is that I'm going
down at a gradient of negative 1 so I'm
gonna get any of these guys let's see
that one that one and all the rest of
difference okay so yeah yeah it's weird
however just thinking through like what
did we need to know to do that we need
to recognize this was happening it's not
obvious at all
okay just like when you look at the
integral you like that then there's
supposed to be some substitution or some
identity what is it well if we remember
this then we can say yeah all right I
can deal with that then you have to
unpack what on earth that means right
which is this we first tried to use that
just by solutions right but in this
context you can see it works in
coordinate geometry as well with
spectacular results so do you see how I
step now you see this okay it's not that
complicated if I were to say do
something like this how could I take a
problem like that and use that to my
advantage into in solving this yeah like
this I know what happened to never close
close right so if I could take advantage
of that I'll write this as cos of the
compliment which is I own to minus that
and then I'm just going to proceed the
way I did before
the differences are gonna be I'm gonna
have a shift here and some things are
gonna be maybe facing this way with
before they were facing that way and
that's the only difference
okay so I expect it all look like this
but with some shift in some translation